Dreamflow is the best place to build and
ship cross-platform applications. So,
let me show you around. You can start a
project with a prompt, a template, or a
blank project. And that's what we're
going to do. When Dreamflow opens up,
there are four main areas. The preview
section where your app is running in
real time, and you can interact with it,
or turn on inspect mode, and you can
select any widget to change it. You can
see that it gets selected in the widget
tree over here, your second section. The
third section is your properties panel,
which is in here. This is where you can
edit any property on your widget. So, if
I want to come in here and edit the
properties, I can do that. The fourth
section is over here with your agent.
Let's close this up. And we've got some
app ideas that the agent gives you. Or
if you're opening a project, you'll see
some next steps, but we already have a
plan, so we're going to toggle this off.
I went over to Dribble and found the
most popular UI of all time. Let's see
how Dreamflow does at building this. So,
I'm going to drop that image in here and
select GPT5 and tell the agent create
this component. Focus on visual
fidelity. The agent is going to
understand the image, our prompt, look
through the project, make a plan, and
execute it. All right, this is looking
great except for one thing. I want these
buttons to be the same size. So, I'm
going to go into inspect mode here,
select my component, and double click
into it. And then select this context
right here. Right click and I'm going to
add this to our agent and then just ask
it to make the cancel button the same
height as the create button. That's
great. I want to make one more quick
edit here. And so I'm going to go into
these colors right here. And if you
right click, you can see this prompt
edit. And I'm just going to say add one
more color.
Beautiful. Okay. Next, let's ask our
agent to create a color palette and some
theming based on this. create color
theming based on the current design.
Great. So, we can see this color theme
right here. If we go into our theme
settings, we've got our typography and
our style constants right here. So, if
we go in and make a change to one of
these right here, we can see it
propagate throughout the app. Great. But
I'm going to push that back for now. And
let's create a page for all the events
you create. Okay, this looks great.
Let's create a new event here.
Beautiful. Next, let's add a logo. But I
wanted an SVG and so I want to use this
package on PubDev, a package repository
with over 50,000 packages. So I'm just
going to copy this right here and tell
the agent add an SVG logo with this
package. Okay, there it is. There's just
a placeholder there. Let's replace that
by adding our SVG asset here. So I can
add it in here or just drag and drop it
in. Great. We've added it in there. And
if we want to see it in the code, we can
jump into the code here. Go into our
assets. And there it is. Okay, great.
Let's just add that to the UI. So, we're
going to back to preview. Let's go into
inspect mode. Select our SVG. Come into
our properties here. Select the
constructor, which will be an asset. And
let's grab a path to our image right
there. Let's rightclick, copy path, and
paste it in. Beautiful. Next, let's wire
this up to a backend so our data can
persist. And we've got Superbase and
Firebase. and I'm going to connect to
Firebase. Create a new project and
configure Firebase. Generate the client
code. Okay, great. I added an on signin
in Firebase. And so we can go in now.
Now let's add an event.
Beautiful. Last thing to do is to deploy
our app. And you can do that with one
click to the web, iOS, and Android. We
can't wait to see what you'll build in
DreamFlow.